In this section, we'll talk about how
to build user interfaces for wearables.
The important thing about Android Wear
is that it uses the same underlying
framework as Android on phones does, so
anything you know about Android
applies to wearables as well.
Key difference is, you want to design
your app to work well on a wearable,
you can't just smoosh down your
phone app to fit on a watch,
you really need to rethink your UI to
make sure it looks good on a wearable.
A really good question you
should ask yourself is this,
what couldn't we do on the phone
that we can do now on the wrist?
What now becomes possible?
So in this section you'll learn about
the additional widgets that we've given
app developers to use that
are wearable specific, and
that will give a common look
to your Android wear app.